[Music]
good afternoon
welcome to the programming session in
the afternoon we're going to jump right
in and get started with
gary gaye who's going to be talking
about getting things logged
yeah thank you very much i'm not sure
if the screens are on
but i will start anyway so
my name is gargadorcia and i'm working
at system one
which is an ad tech company but i will
not talk about marketing
neither about our business models and
neither about the statistical models we
are using although there are some
interesting problems
we are doing a lot of time series
forecasting
hierarchical models with quite large
amount of data
working with multi-arm bandits and so on
but i will just focus on
all the open source or packages that we
have built mainly to use
our in production and you can see a
couple examples here we
have written thin layers around gdbc
drivers
so that you can easily connect to let's
say to snowflake
from r and a few other things like being
able to use
grpc right from our either as a server
or as a client
and a few other things and i will focus
on this uh
logging for our package but before
i focus on this logger package i would
like to clarify what i mean
by using or in production and what is in
production
and i included a couple projects from
the past years i will skip
many of these and we'll just focus on
some important points
like i will not mention the first one
that was terrible but this
is happening in a lot of companies i
think writing batch
jobs in r that is to be run in an
automated way maybe
triggered by jenkins or cron schedule or
something like that
uh maybe just generating reports or
doing some etl
processes or doing some daily operations
like
charging fees on customers card and so
on
so this is pretty common but i think
there's no standard way of
logging everything in production which
can be really useful if something goes
wrong also you want to get notified if
there's any errors
with your jobs i've been using r to be
integrated in web applications
jeffrey horner's or apache module was
great
it makes it fairly easy to have scalable
apis written in r although there are
some issues like security that you
should take seriously
also you need a way of tracking all the
errors in the central place and so on
and just wanted to mention another thing
using r4 stream processing
is not a standard thing i think but you
can definitely do that
for example i was working at the fintech
company and we had the debit card
transactions coming in in real time
and we had some r scripts uh doing the
real-time notifications of our customers
via text message email push
notifications and so on so that's
totally doable but it's not really
standard so there are some
ways to improve there so just
abstracting the survey
i think using or in production is mainly
using rv without manual intervention
so having a cron or jenkins or apr
request triggered the job
also you should use some containerized
environment
i would like to emphasize it's not as
simple as putting everything in a docker
image and you are always set but
you have to fix your r version your r
package versions your operating system
versions
for example if you're using debian
testing and the
apt team decides to do a major version
update for example for the postgres
client
overnight then your jobs might fail
also you have to use like a standard our
profile and so on
i will skip security that's a totally
different topic but but really important
and i will focus on these so you really
have to monitor the jobs to get notified
if there's some problem you want to get
a notification as a developer
and also you want to notify the users of
your our applications
for example in our case the buyers of
different campaigns
and it's i think not enough to monitor
the errors but you have to log
everything so that if there's a problem
you can debug that
pretty easily so some more motivation
here
10 seconds
so this 10 second video really well
describes how i feel about the r code
i've written 10 years ago or let's say
yesterday and i like to use this
animation
to highlight the importance of version
control but
i think that's true for logging as well
for example you have this super
important business stuff.r
script that you would like to run and
the only output you get is this one soft
script out of bonds i think the most
frequent this search term on stack
overflow
and here at least you get some hints
there's a function called
f and g but if you get an error like
this one dot subset to
errors you have no idea what have
happened so
uh logging is important i've seen
this design in a lot of scripts so
you're looping over some vector
and printing the iterating variable so
that you know
where the script is happening so that's
just the poor man's progress bar or
uh so that you know where the error
script failed
or there are some fancier versions of
that logging the timestamp and the
percentage
left which works great for example if
you have an output like this one
at least you know that the script failed
after the 17th iteration but it's not
perfect
also you can log to file by sync or cat
or you can have your own homebrew
function to do the logging uh
to log file and this works in most cases
but for example if you are like forking
the r process
let me just scroll down a little bit
your log lines can
be mixed up and then this subset to
error happens you have no idea
in which part that happened so i think
it's a time to get a proper
r package for logging and of course i
did my homework i looked around on cran
what packages are available for logging
and there are quite a few i
tried to use this nice regular
expression to filter for all the
packages related to logging and
obviously i did a very bad job with that
anyway there are at least 10 packages
doing logging on cranbot there were some
issues i will not get into the details
i've written a pretty long
apologetics about why i'm not using the
other packages
uh if you're interested please check the
github page
anyway i came up with a design which can
be used for all the other r packages so
this is a design which is flexible
enough to fit
all the needs of your users posted this
on twitter got some
good feedback so ended up working on
this package
this is called logger usage is hopefully
fairly straightforward
so you load the package and then you
have this log underscore info
warn error debug and trace functions
where you can just pass a string
so it will just print to the console the
log level
timestamp and the message you have
posted there
and there are some formatters by default
if the glue packages
installed on your computer that will be
used so you can use variable names or r
expressions
that will be evaluated in your string
glue will do the string interpolation
and
here log the number of rows in the
dataset
and so on there are some helper
functions
in logger and i will just show you a
couple examples
for example this log eval function will
evaluate your
our expression this one and also log the
results so
you can see that this was wrong this is
the result this is useful if you just
want to record
the changing values of a variable in a
loop or in an r script
and this is my favorite one so log
warnings and
note the plural form so once you issue
this command
from that time you will get detailed
logs about
all the warnings thrown by any or
function for example here
i think this is useful so that no right
away when the
warning happened with the exact
timestamp
not like the default or behavior
printing all the warnings at the end of
the r script
a few other things so logger is mainly
to be used
in our scripts and not really in
interactive mode
so this is a quick example loading the
logger package
listing all the available packages on
cran logging the number of packages
available on cran
and just iterating over all the letters
of the english alphabet
counting the number of packages
including that letter
and depending on the number of packages
we will either use trace or debug log
level
to print the name of the package with
the actual number sorry print the actual
letter with the number of
packages related so this is the output
you can see that the trace
log messages did not show up because by
default we are using the debug
log level but i will share more details
on that later
this was one of the first user requests
can we have colorized outputs
now that's possible if if you're
interested although i would like to
emphasize that
uh if you want to grab like outputs it's
probably not the best thing but
that's definitely doable so let me give
you a more structured overview on how
this logger package works
and i will use this example of calling
the log info
on this string and in logger actually
these four steps are happening
so first we check if the log threshold
is met
so this is fairly easy so here we know
that the info
level is sorry the log level is info and
the log threshold could be set to let's
say
error which means i do not want this to
be logged
so i just exit early and this is
happening fairly quickly so there's not
much overhead
on an average laptop like this one this
happens in 20 microseconds so not
speaking about milliseconds it's 20
microseconds
which is important so that you can put
as many logging functions in your
production scripts as you wish
if you don't really need the log outputs
you can just set the higher log
threshold
so next step after the log level
threshold was math is using the
formatter function
which is just focusing on this part so
the hello curly braces name
will be transformed to hello world
because the name was replaced by word
so this is just creating the log message
that is to be recorded later
in the means of a log record a log
record
as a rendered version of the log message
and this simple layout is just adding
the log level
prefix a timestamp and the actual
message
but you can use other layouts like json
and and
other things as well the fourth step
defines where the log
record has to be delivered which can be
a console
it can be a file or it can be a database
or maybe slack
and the end result is here
so once you load the package all these
functions are automatically run
so that means that logger is ready to be
used right away
no need to set up anything although you
can fine tune it
to your needs
let me go through all the related atomic
items of lager log levels are just
integers so making this comparison is
cheap
we have the log message formatters for
example the one that i mentioned
previously
that is using blue in the background but
you can use s
printf maybe because glue is not
installed or you just prefer that syntax
and there are a few others and honestly
you can write a log message formatter
pretty easily
you just have to make sure that you are
transforming whatever object
is passed to a string next step
is the layout which is again the layout
simple is just adding the log level
prefix
timestamp and the message but you can
fine tune that to your needs
i have this generator function which
provides you
quite a few meta variables that you can
use
in your generator for example it can
automatically log the hostname
where you're running the r script the
process id the namespace from which you
have been calling this logger function
and so on and of course you can have
layouts for example in json and and
other cases as well
the log record destination has one of
the most
complex things i think you can log to
console
file you can log to both and you can
deliver the messages maybe to slack or
other instant messaging
systems you can send the messages to
syslog you can send
the log records to a live stream or
to a database table and so on and this
is a recent feature
being able to use a log record
appender in an asynchronous way and to
show you a quick example of that i'm
defining my own appender function which
hopefully also demonstrates how easy it
is to create your own
functions so this is uh just writing
to a given file but doing that pretty
slowly
after sleeping for a second so once you
start using this
appender and you log 25 lines
uh you can guess what happens here this
script run for 25 seconds
not doing anything besides logging so if
you are using that in a production
application
you are blocking your production job by
logging which is not cool at all
instead of that there's an async way of
delivering the log record
to the destination and if you're
interested it's pretty detailed in the
documentation how it's
done to keep it short we have a local
message queue
where we are just pushing the log
records and the actual delivery is
done by a background process which is
monitored by
your main r session so just to
show you a quick example of that you
just need to wrap your repenter function
in appender async and then it will
create your temporary storage
for the message queue it will start
the background process and monitor it
for you for free
and then when you run the very same
stuff you will get
the results within a few milliseconds
instead of waiting for
the log records actually delivered and
after that if you are checking on the
log file you can see that the background
process
is still delivering the log records but
your
r script managed to finish the job in
time
last thing about the logger definition
it's not
that simple as described here because
you can actually have multiple
thresholds multiple formatters and
layouts
if you would like to fine-tune that to
your needs you do not
have to do that but if you would like to
deliver errors to a database
all the trace logs to your file and the
info messages to your console
that's totally possible because of time
constraints i will just go through this
real quickly about i will post the
slides later online
and you will find these examples so
uh you can just stack all these
log records pretty easily
there are some helper functions and i
will
just mention some of these so there's
tick tock logging which is
just printing the number of seconds
since the previous
uh log request some other functions that
i already mentioned for example the log
warnings these guys will automatically
capture all the messages
warnings and errors thrown by r and log
it properly so that you know
when those errors messages and
and so on happened there's a helper
function for shiny
so this is a fairly simple shiny
application
and this line might not be familiar so
just
imputing this single line to your app it
will monitor
all your inputs so all these free
inputs in your shiny app and will give
you free logging
of all the changes happening in your
application so
just putting that line in your shiny app
you will get detailed logs of
what inputs were changed by the user
which is i think really useful
uh to track down how users are managing
your app and what errors might have
happened
using logger in our packages and this is
the main thing why i started to work on
loggers so that
it's flexible enough to be used in an r
package
as the r package developer imagined what
things should be logged
and giving access to the user to fine
tune where
the log messages should be logged so a
few examples there's this moto r package
which is a wrapper around
python's photo free module so this is a
simple way of interacting with
aws for example you can read files from
s3
by just specifying the object and the
function to be used
and it will download the file store in a
temporary file
read everything and clear up your
workspace you get some logging for free
if you don't like that you can just
kill that and you can get rid of the log
messages or you can actually
update the log threshold to be traced so
that you get more detailed
uh logging for example here it will do
the dq
decompressing it will log the change in
the file size
and also it will log the cleanup process
if you don't like that again you can
just set let's say an error or very high
log level threshold and you will get rid
of all those messages
another example uh for logging
is this one this is a pretty common
pattern in our scripts using dbi
and hard-coding passwords and host names
in our scripts
i didn't like that approach so i was
thinking about something better
and just to keep it short by the way if
you are interested there are some other
related slides on my homepage
for this a database connection reference
can be as simple as this one for example
just using sql lite
for that you just provide the driver and
let's just use a temporary file
for the actual database if you want to
run a simple query like this one select
42
you get logging for free again if you
want to get rid of that it's really easy
to turn that down but i think it's
really important to have this in
production jobs like you see
how or when we are making the database
connection
you get the actual sql statement logged
to your console
file slack whatever you get the number
of rows which is important when you are
checking
production job output and you see that
no rows were returned and so on
and there are some attributes also
logged which might be useful
more complex example is using mysql
and just using the shiny demo server
provided by our studio
although the password is not that secret
but still it's not very cool to have
this in an
unencrypted yaml file you can use let's
say amazon
kms to do the encryption and decryption
for you
so using this database connection can be
as easy as this one
you write your sql and this package will
do the decryption
via kms for you log the actual sql
results and so on uh yeah it's fork safe
and there are a few other features that
might be interesting please check the
slides everything posted on my
personal home page we have some other
packages all these packages have
i think pretty detailed package down
documentation if you miss anything
please let me know and i will be happy
to improve the documentation
and thank you very much and just happy
logging to everyone so thank you okay
thank you thank you gary that was a
great overview of the logger package we
have time for maybe one or two quick
questions
so you did skip over it right at the end
but how does the logger package
log computations inside mcl apply or
parallel l apply
what was the middle part of can i just
have a look
so with mcl apply when you are forking
uh
it will actually fork all the appender
functions and formatter functions or
whatever you have defined and we'll just
use those
if you are afraid of making uh
that in the case when you are using a
database insert as the appender
uh actually the ddbr package is aware of
that so when you are
forking the process it can check if the
pid changed and if it did then it will
just create a new connection
automatically so it's making all these
processes pretty fork safe
one more quick question uh logs or data
how do you analyze the logs
yeah that's a great question as well so
it really depends on how you define
your log message uh layouts all right it
will be pretty difficult to go back to
the slides anyway
you can define the log layout to be
let's say your json
line object so this way you are just
logging json blobs
and you can just parse that with your
favorite tool so
you if you want to analyze your logs
probably you should not
use the default text layout but
you can also deliver the log records to
your database so you have that in a
structured way
right away okay thank you very much
thank you